(Mark)
He's disgusting.
Bernard?
He's not even like her.
He's an airplane technician.
I mean, come on.
And he talks too much.
That's why I like you.
You don't talk.
You just listen.
- It's good.
[bell dings]
Okay.
And the captain has turned on
the "fasten seat belt" sign.
Got a little turbulence
coming up.
Should be no problem.
Just remain in your seat
until the sign is turned off.
Thank you
for your cooperation.
Okay.
Excuse me.
I'm gonna go to the bathroom.
Hi, excuse me.
- Yeah?
- Yeah.
I'm gonna need you
to take your seat.
The "fasten seat belt"
sign is on.
Yeah, I'm just gonna go
to the bathroom for a second.
I'll be
right back, okay?
I understand
what you want to do.
Unfortunately,
I'm gonna need you
to observe
the "fasten seat belt" sign.
That'd be
much appreciated.
Right, it's just
I read on the Internet
that it's not
against the law
for me to go
to the bathroom
while the "fasten seat belt"
sign is on, so...
"Seat belt" sign
is on.
But is it
against the law, though?
The light is on.
[inhales sharply]
Is it against the law?
You see
that there's a picture
of a seat belt
on that sign.
I know, but is it
against the law, though?
The "fasten seat belt" sign
is on.
But is it against
the law, though?
- "Seat belt" sign is on.
- But is it against the law?
- "Seat belt" sign.
- It's on.
- Law.
- "Seat belt" sign is on.
- Legal.
- Lawful.
- "Seat belt" sign is on.
- Sir, you're being difficult.
- Law.
- You're being very difficult.
- Law, law, law.
- Seat belt, seat belt.
- Not illegal, not illegal.
- Okay.
- Legal.
- Fasten--
- Fasten your seat--
- Legal.
- Sir.
- I have to piss.
And I have to shit
in the toilet.
Can you lower
your voice?
[whispering]
I have to piss,
and I have to shit.
Okay, lower
your intensity.
You're louder
than me.
You're yelling
in my face.
Sir, you're the one who I think
needs to tone it down right now.
You are
screaming at me.
[whispering]
You're hurting my eardrums.
[mouthing words]
That wasn't
a word.
You're not saying
a word there.
This is a word.
- That's not--
- That's a word.
That's not a word.
That's a tongue trick.
Okay, sir.
Sir, sir.
If you would like--
I would not like to.
I would not like
to sit down.
What I'd like to do is go
take a shit in the bathroom...
because it's not
against the law.
So I'm gonna go
to the bathroom, okay?
Mark with a K.
[tense music]
♪
[people scream]
[people screaming]
[dramatic choral music]
♪
[people screaming]
[exhales deeply]
[bell dings]
And your captain has turned off
the "fasten seat belt" sign.
Feel free to move
around the cabin.
Thank you
for your cooperation.
[dark music]